today's Monday minute is step interfere  there are things that you need to do in  your business and in your life to  achieve your goals that you are afraid  of and you need to get over that fear  and do them if you want to bust out of  your average life the first time I got  up in front of a camera to make a  recording I was nervous I was scared I  was sweating my heart was pounding the  first time I got up on stage to do my  first keynote presentation at a  conference the whole week before that I  was secretly hoping that they would call  me and tell me evidence cancelled you  don't have to come it's off I was so  afraid but I knew that I needed to do  these things to get me to where I am now  and I'm going to have to face more  things that I'm going to afraid up to  get me to the next step so if there's  something that you're afraid of it's  okay to be afraid you don't have to be  Superman fear is normal but don't let  that fear hold you back from doing  something great belief